[Música]
[Aplausos]
ai ana picar o picar o homem
here
[Música]
ficar o meu mel
é é
[Música]
ayanna pe caruaru pe caruaru pe homem
er e ayanna pícaro picar o homem
er e ficar ou eu é picar o seu mérito é
é esse canto que eu acabei de cantar pra
vocês é um canto cerimonial que meu avô
ensinou para o meu pai que então
repassou pra mim esses e outros cantos
nós cantamos nas noites de carpi noite
já o açúcar que são cerimônias sagradas
quando nos conectamos com o nosso grande
para universal com nossos espíritos
espírito de nossos antepassados
espíritos visíveis e invisíveis que nos
acompanha por meu povo o povo é passar a
criação do mundo começou quando tudo era
escuro no tempo do início do mundo não
existia nem fala nem movimento mas já
existe o pensamento maconha com o
criador do universo
certo dia se sentiu sozinho então
decidiu criar o avô sol e ao avô lua do
namoro entre os dois nasceu a terra
ele então pegou o seu tabaco sagrado
miró fez uma cerimônia e assoprou em
direção ao mundo
nesse instante a primeira célula de
primeira célula de vida começou a pulsar
e assim milhares de outras células
começaram o início da criação e da vida
na terra
nós também temos um bastão sagrado para
nosso povo aqui dentro de si bastão
existem várias camadas várias dimensões
as dimensões das águas dimensões dos
líquidos dimensões do ouro das nuvens
cada dimensão existe para sustentar a
terra
nesse eixo da terra
essa e outras histórias eram contadas
pelo meu avô arquiteto grande como ibai
a no terreiro da aldeia ou dentro da
grande maloca enquanto tocava o car isso
ia contando histórias durante toda a
noite para nós os velhos são os nossos
grandes bibliotecas são sábios são os
anciões que conseguem nos contar desde o
início a origem da nossa vida até os
dias de hoje
isso para nós é muito valioso porque nos
conecta como um fio invisível que nos
liga enquanto laços familiares
nós temos leis antigas leis que vem
através da oralidade da palavra
nós temos grandes clãs clãs do gent
peixe poema só como nascemos desde o
início temos gente pedra gente a árvore
porque o criador criou todos nós como
irmãos maiores e menores e por isso
todos temos igual importância nesse
universo eu eu nasci entre os dois
mundos entre o mundo indígena eo mundo
não indígena
me sinto como uma tradutora entre esses
dois mundos
eu me tornei mãe mulher advogada então
comecei a compreender esse sistema de
leis que é muito diferente dos nós
porque além dos brancos
ela não serve para proteger a
subsistência a família e nem as futuras
gerações
o nosso sistema de leis é um sistema de
leis incoerente
de um lado temos latifúndio e de outro
temos uma reserva ambiental
eu pergunto como é que os animais têm
vivido entre o deserto e uma reserva
encurralados como é que os seres humanos
estão vivendo aqui na terra
a maioria está sozinho isso é muito
preocupante para nós porque porque tudo
está interligado
as relações do mundo todas dependem umas
das outras
tudo é uma relação só que quando a
pessoa já não sabe de onde vem o seu
alimento não sabe o tempo do plantio da
colheita ou das estações
ela se desconecta dessa essência divina
que têm cada um
hoje eu tô aqui pra contar essas
histórias pra vocês porque eu acredito
que se nós colocarmos outros valores no
centro das relações humanas como amor
como a simplicidade como o afeto a
delicadeza ea colaboração mas poderemos
trabalhar de uma outra maneira junto com
a terra mas poderemos trabalhar curando
a terra
isso é o que nós pensamos isso que nós
rezamos enquanto estamos nessas noites
sagradas de carpi quando bate o vento
quando os grilos cantam quando os sapos
canto
nós defendemos a floresta porque na
floresta tudo é vida tudo pulsa tudo
respira
quando vocês olharem um povo indígena
lembrem-se nós temos muito conhecimento
e esse conhecimento
ele vem do grande pai universal esse
universo ele é infinito
ele é muito encantado por isso eu
acredito que se cada um para e pensar o
que é que eu vim fazer aqui na terra
o que é que eu quero deixar para meus
filhos para os meus netos para os meus
bisnetos
para nós esses conhecimentos da floresta
podem ser invisíveis aos olhos e ouvidos
de quem não aprendeu a ler essa natureza
esse universo
mas para nós é o que nós temos de mais
sagrado porque nos mostra de onde viemos
e para onde vamos
eu espero que essa história faça sentido
para alguns de vocês porque eu defendo
nós devemos nos unir nós podemos nos
fortalecer juntos mas precisamos desta
terra e para que isso aconteça para que
a vida continue brotando do vento dessa
terra que tudo nos dá
nós precisamos fazer algo a mais